okay thank you very much understand 25
minutes so I will be late okay so what I
let's keep it what I would like to tell
you i will start would like to start
with three motivating examples and try
to convince you that pattern matching
can be useful for solving all of them
and actually convene at oriole calculus
analytical techniques information theory
can actually help us to extract some
information knowledge so in the first
example sit this one you have DNA or any
other biological sequence and this
sequence very interesting it has many
different regions for example there are
some region the red one that geez reside
there are some others transcript starts
were if the promoting area that tells
you something interesting coming in
there if intro that has some other job
to do and you would like to learn
something about the sequence how you can
do it you take a small word a special
one and you prop this sequence and you
are counting the number of occurrences
of this word and it turns out that in
different region you might have
different occurrences I call it exact
string matching problem I'm counting the
number of occurrences of a given word or
maybe a set of words and this tells me
something about the underlying text in
another example which is google is a
completely different problem but pattern
matching silk can be useful here i put
three or five keywords and i'm looking
for web pages that contain them he had
interesting first of all this words will
be right now symbols of a bigger
alphabet and you can see that they
appear in bold but they appear this
words appear in this web page is not
consecutively like I did it here like a
string but rather the subsequent it
means a pier with a gap
okay and if I would like to rank this
web pages from let's say from the point
of view of the most interesting or the
pp value I need to understand the number
of occurrences of these keywords as sub
sequences and the gap between them do
matter by the way if you want to find
the worst fungal skin hamlet you won't
find it at a string but you find it at a
subsequent with gut about 14 symbols
between each symbol okay so a randomness
makes funny things and we have to
somehow make sure that when so when the
sequence of string becomes significant
and that's why they are notice of that
kind of thing the subsequent analysis
matter finally twitter if I take to
Twitter's I would like to know
automatically whether they talk about
the same or not so how can I do it in
general I take two strings and I want to
know how close they are and the way to
do it I will count the number of Commons
upwards how many sup words here and here
are the fam and I count the number and
if i do it i can say that two strings
are closer to each other if the number
of common sub words are bigger than than
a decade and then I can use it actually
to classify or Twitter sports politics
science and so on and so on the problem
that I need here as string complexity
which is defined as for 20 for one word
the number of distinct sup words for to
word this is called joint string
complexity the number of common words so
these are three examples from a big
bigger area that I call pattern matching
problems and there are several of them
and I would like let me give you a
a little general definition first and
and what it is about so given a word and
attacks and this attacks let's see let
it be of length and and usually texted
generated randomly but not always and
the word could be a word of length m or
a set of words okay the beta question
that I would be interested in because
this will tells me a lot about the tags
I will be counting the number of
occurrences of this word a word a sub
set of words and maybe sub sequences in
a bigger text and this is my parameter
that I'm interested in and then you can
define different pattern matching
problem one of them is the basic one
exact pattern matching that I have one
string and I count the number of
occurrences of such a string in a
randomly usually randomly generated text
memoryless mark affair or something else
general string matching is actually much
more interesting now I have a set of
words and I have a special word i call
it w0 which is a set of words and each
of this is also said their words but
then I call w0 as forbidden sad and hear
what I might be interested in general
i'm interested in occurrences of all
words the red one w1w d in attacks in
which no word from w0 does occur so this
is a forbidden word and actually when
this is eroded is called generalized
pattern matching if it is not empty then
I have under the condition and non
butter from WG ok i might have all of
them by the way empty and then i'm
looking for a text in which non on w0
cares to and this is a constraint
pattern matching ok more and this is
more general that we can see the
subsequent pattern matching now I have a
a word maybe a set of words but now i'm
looking at
currencies of this word at a subsequent
so with Maya current position I one or I
to or I am and there is a gap
intuitively between them and I might
consider a lot of different thing I'm a
machine I'm I assume that the gap is
bounded by some numbers on a machine
that some symbols have to be in within
bonded to region and some not which is
if all of them the gaps are unbounded
they call it unconstrained pattern
matching so for example the word date
that not occur in hidden pattern but
they'll care as it as a string but the
subsequent as you can see it so this
string pattern matching sometimes called
hidden pattern magic and finally in lamp
as if and other kind of things what you
do actually your partner is the part of
the text let's call itself a pity party
but doesn't matter okay so i hope i
convince you that there are a lot of
interesting stuff going on there and you
need a collection on all of them in one
place and techniques to analyze it and i
want to deliver this to you so we are
just finishing with my friend philip a
book it should appear may be in
june/july maybe indian in on display in
in isit they discover a Lalique pattern
matching from DNA to Twitter i I try to
give a motivation from both of them
different ideas and different techniques
being used and actually hear what it is
so we have so what we talked that
exactly part of matching and i will give
you an example how we do make analysis
trying to explain to you analytic here
the constraint pattern matching is for
DK codes when the text has some
constraint that for example the 0 has to
be separated by one's of doesn't matter
or is it something more general general
string matching the very interesting
problem you're at
I explained to it you have a set of
words and maybe set of forbidden words
and you try to understand how many them
or care the problem is that the set of
words might be very dependent some of
these words might be part of the other
works and how to analyze it and the
subsequent visitors of the first part of
the book explained basically present
analytical tools from complex analysis
and you are not surprised about this and
trying to predict probabilistic behavior
and I give you an example in a second
second part of the book is basically
application so we start with digital
trees tries but Richard tried digital
sorry when you have set of independent
strings and you build the tree digital
tree and you lie to understand profile
of such a tree how many how many know do
you have on level l how many what is the
path length from the root to a leaf and
so on and so on you are much more
interested in this one because suffix
tree is what we are using in length of
77 now you have one big drink and you
take suffixes and you put it in digital
tree and you try to understand it what
we are proving and we prove it many
years ago but we put it here is that the
random tries tries a coming from digital
tree from the word retrieval random
tries resemble suffix tree so whatever
technique i have here can be used here
that is much harder to analyze lam
positive 78 we right now have a limiting
distribution for redundancy of lentils
if 78 as you remember it was an open
problem for a long time and string
complexity is something new that we did
with Philip we Street their application
when you have two strings they're
looking for the number of common sub
words ok so this is if you interest that
what is there what I would like to do
right now I would like to give you an
example of an analogous and try to show
you how we actually approaching it the
tomb a tool that we are using
combinatorial calculus
and analytical method by analytic method
I mean method of complex allow that
apply to district problems this is what
the group and other vulgar it is doing
for last few years so I remind you what
I don't talk only about chapter one
exactly matching the simplest case and I
want to tell you how we can do the
analogies so I have one word I have a
text text generated by memory less
Markov can be handled not much more
complicated and I'm trying to understand
the number of occurrences of the word ww
is given text patter is given in a
random text symbolic calculus and I'll
Erica tools so to know nobody is
surprised no one surprised by using
generating function of a language and
language in the collection of words so
here it is defined V the dummy parameter
when I will go from military calculous
to analytical took the extra got some
topics i will make thee complex but
right now if a dummy parameter is
basically you take all words from the
language you multiply you waited by
probability and you razy to the length
of the words why is it interesting
because if i have collection of two
languages or two languages and i
concatenate them one of them in kolkata
neither that I'm fake a word from one
language and i take another word and
concatenated generating function do
multiply and that's the whole thing so a
complicated convolutions and behavior
becomes basically algebraic equation so
there is one language that is very
important and i cannot go anywhere
without explaining this so if you have a
pattern like so this is my pattern w a b
c a b this batter had a structure when I
say occurrences I mean that the putter
can overlap when they do occur notice
that here if I shift this pattern
the first two symbols and the last two
symbols are the same so when I shim then
I have you can see that this to do
overlap and the most interesting part of
the part that is what is here and I call
the set s so in general when I have a
pattern and the first k symbols of the
same in the last case symbols which
means when I shift it by n minus K M and
the length of the pattern the last
overlap with the first so i have two
occurrences and the word starting from
here from k plus 1 cases here is the
this length this set of this words are
very important let us go alkyl
autocorrelation fat i define generating
function like this and here have an
example we're here when I have a pattern
Bab my fat is empty words and a B and
this value case a one-in-three okay this
is a generating function ok now I have
to explain this one to you so I want to
generate a language that's 84 which will
be the set of all words that have
exactly four occurrences of the word w
which which W is give it to me let's say
W is a DA so I want all words that have
exactly four occurrences of W I will
introduce to you three languages
and you ah language are constrains all
words such that W occurs only once at
the end of this world so here if I have
word ABA I don't have a good example
here so i give you the Bellator neck now
here's an example that the word in red
is basically occurs only at the end word
am a set of words M is a little
different so lets you belongs to this
language now when I take you and
concatenate the word w from it I want
exactly two occurrences so he had a good
example I have a word ba and my Alf and
my patters ABA when I concatenate ABA to
be a what do I have I have one
occurrences here and another occurrences
here so so W language is such I'm sorry
M language is such that when I can
calculate W to asset to a word from em
there are exactly two occurrences
exactly two occurrences and finally I
have ultimate that such that you does
not have any occurrences of W but if i
come come come cuddle a with wi have
exactly one so look what i can do right
now how i can create language with four
occurrences I take a word from language
are it has exactly one occurrences of w
here then I take a language I take a
word for language and it has occurrences
at the end but if I concatenate the word
w from previous are I have exactly two I
know that up to here i have exactly two
occurrences of W then i take another
language and another language am and
finish with you let's count Alan your
chris is do I have
one two three four so my here is the
funny thing that the language that
contained exactly our occurrences of the
word w is basically concatenation of
language all our minus 1 concatenation
of a menu so if I tell you how to
construct the three languages I can
basically give you a construction of
Cuba something that I'm interested in
and this and then and these are
basically relation between fans let's
look at this relation I don't have much
time but let's look at this one so I'm
taking a word from language to language
you is the one that has only no
occurrences unless it's on the left if i
add a simple one more symbol from the
alphabet what can happen maybe w does
occur so then it belongs to language and
or it doesn't occur but it is not
anymore empty so I have to say u minus a
now it is very easy to translate this in
terms of generating function BTW
clickers generating function of this
generating function of the z m u minus
one if i do it i have basically system
of equations for fat and if i put random
generating function there early I mean
random text then I get generating
function which basically gives me
correlation a relation between language
and U and V and you remember what I told
you about Chi sub R this apar this
language was r times r r minus 1 times
you so the generating function of this
is basically our of the times r to the
power minus one of the times you of g
and i know how to compute them
from this one so I get everything I want
okay I understand i have seven minutes
correct good so once I have this one now
I'm going from combinatorics to analytic
tools and so I going to quickly show you
few things that we can get you can get a
military girl variant is not trivial
because the autocorrelation set occur
there I can tell you probability that
there are exactly five occurrences I can
tell give you pretty pretty precise
central limit law as well as large
deviation okay let's let's leave it
there I believe me we can get it and let
it in the book I want to show you one
non trivial example of this that we have
to go from chapter 12 chapter 4 from
from exacting magic to generalize drink
much so what's happened and and and this
is true in many cases that I'm looking
for occurrence of the word w1 and also
traces of another word w2 so if I have a
word and I take any sub word of it this
sub word if the original word occurred
very often that the support must occur
very often obviously but I would like to
know whether the sub word of a very
frequent word is also significant or not
I cannot look at the number of our
currency there's another sub word but
very close to this one I cannot decide
significance of occurrences of this
based on this word itself if I know that
this is significant because because this
threshold for significant will be
completely different and so I have to do
so I have to consider occurrences of WM
w 1 and W together and actually base my
significant level based on the
conditional entropy assuming that the
word w is very frequent
what is the average of the recursive w
okay and the transfer we know it will be
a function of an it groove linearly but
this constant is very different and to
computing it is not easy you actually
have to use tools that we develop a
generous pattern matching the blue graph
or some others think that will allow you
to compute why the important is an
example from denison duranium so they
they probe so they wrote a paper they're
trying to try to count the occurrences
of some string here it is and and and
also string that are close to it so this
is original strings are strings very
closely because of mutation and so on
you have to assume that sometimes this
might be mutated into something very
close so the this part of the of the
stable is what biology's would do they
basically take all of this word count
the number of currencies and compute
this score this car is basically the
difference between the mid / the Vario
that you know and let's look at this
word it's very close to this one it
occurs a lot it's ranked at number five
if I consider this word without any
reference to this one but if you
consider the matter that I show you that
the threshold actually is based on the
fact that is very frequent this word
from rank 5 because rank four thousand
so because you have to shift it in order
for this word to be significant it
cannot come from the fact that this
frequent you have to count from
something else it has to be way above
the threshold or just occurring this one
so and these techniques allowed you to
do things like this and to get you the
central limit result if it's necessary
or any distribution that occurs in in
application of pattern matching from
exact
two subsequent pattern matching let me
finish I'm sure you're ready for lunch
so I'm done
giving you permission so you're rather
dispute in that application it's busy
used to compute the p-value under the
null hypothesis of random string theory
so you're trying to say that is there
some information from your randomness in
the string and you're trying to cover a
key by your face and no sausages that
were you so so here's another way to add
the same question I'm probably a
database and I'm getting some answer and
then I have another query to the
database and I'm getting another answer
I want to know how this new also how
much more information is your answer
actually tells me about the database and
the two that we have there can you give
you one of the possible answer so this
is this conditional exactly exactly and
this because it is general and because
of the analytical tools if analytical
supplies they you gives you extremely
precise analysis you can ask steph under
there and the french group because they
do it all the time that was philly
flagellar our friend actually told us
how to actually apply the analytic tools
to community oryx so discreet problems
are being solved by complex and all of
these tools
thank you speak